do you make the same to been absolutely
sir that you will absolutely accept the
result of this election i will look at
it at the time
it's rigged that's just not right I mean
this is a fair
first of all the election is a
state-by-state tissue to sew to think
that some sort of conspiracy exists that
elections can be rigged that's just that
that that's not good for the system when
in fact it's not happening during all
the debates we had like four minutes
tonight spent on the deficit four
minutes out of all the debates and then
there were really just a couple of
minutes spent on the entitlements
Medicaid Medicare Social Security when
these are really really huge issues and
not mentioned once or drugs not
mentioned once was the legalization of
marijuana and the fact that the number
one category of a rest in this country
in the last year is marijuana-related
that that is flabbergasting and of
course completely missing economics is a
big part of the last part of the debate
tonight what you think about all that
well Hillary there's a certainty that
Hillary is going to raise taxes there is
a certainty when it comes to trump that
there is uncertainty
I mean he's talking about economic
growth
well you can't count on economic growth
you got to actually cut government
that's the one thing you couldn't count
on when he talks about restricting
immigration that's going to have a
negative impact on the economy so I you
know I I think Trump's toast
there's a lot of leaks from WikiLeaks
emails and the like about the Clinton
campaign what do you think about the
leaks that have happened so far
you know I wish they would be receiving
the attention that they deserve but i'm
afraid that Trump and his continued for
labels seem to take up the Airways look
when Hillary Clinton says one thing in
front of Wall Street and says another
thing in front of main street that's
hypocrisy does it feel to be watching
the debates
all all of the debates that have
happened so far and not being up there
yourself
well I am on the ballot in all 50 states
so the only third party on the ballot in
all 50 states
I think that as a result of my campaign
the libertarian campaign this cycle i
think that could change in the future
and it's because of the showing that we
that we have that we've demonstrated and
that it will be reflected probably next
election cycle if not still winning
I mean all these revelations anything is
possible and of course you have no
chance of winning if you're not in the
rapes